out of common courtesy i would um
explain things all the time anyway
like i would say straight away like hey
you know i've got um you know like you
know i've got a small
you know small dick or i'd be like oh
you know i got a [ __ ] or
[Music]
when you were born did your parents know
that you were intersex
it's kind of hard to tell if your
intersex is normally um
at birth unless you have like your
ambiguous genitalia is so
ambiguous that you obviously notice that
that you know the
person's hermaphrodite slash intersex
yeah
when i was born um i had a uh large
clitoris
um but there was no actual um
immediate concern or anything like that
so i had a vagina and a big clear
respect
yeah you were ready as then as a girl
yeah i was raised as a girl
when did you notice there was a
difference between you
and the other girls i thought i looked
like a girl but
you know according to the whole of my
school and everybody that's known me in
the last 25 years i look like a boy
there was nothing about me that screamed
girl other than the fact that i had a
vagina hole
i had never like hung out with any of
the girls i had
i'd never like like
interacted with them i'd never related
to them
i always had a very raspy voice
i had no chest i was like
i was i was in football teams i was in
basketball teams i was doing the best in
all of my sports
does that feel weird being different
from the other girls
yeah it was just a constant comment i
knew when pe or something was going to
come up something where it
involved like sport activities or
anything to do with gym class
i knew that you know the girls were
going to start you know i wasn't allowed
to get changed with them
in their changing room or anything
because even though
like i say clitoris i say that loosely
my clitoris is basically like a
a very small dick
i can swear yeah yeah so it's so it's
just it's like it's like a very you know
small dick it still has erections um it
still has it's very veiny
and uh yeah i love it so um yeah but
obviously
that was the conflict of interest all
the time it was the where to get changed
who to get changed we used to get
changed
next to like it was this constant like a
battle
like a double-edged sword 24 7. people's
parents were coming up to me
asking me like they were in shock they
were just like there's no way you're a
girl you're a boy
um you know i got asked to put lift up
my shirt a lot
and obviously i had a very masculine
chest people didn't believe me
um you know these are grown adults that
would do this as well
and because of the way i am i didn't see
it as offensive i just
saw them as dumb because if i've told
you that i'm one thing and you're
telling me that i'm not another thing
and you're like
30 35 like that's that makes you look
stupid
no offense i think you're like a fan
[Laughter]
but would that not sometimes i would
feel like
you know maybe they're right like
am i a girl like maybe
this whole girl thing ain't for me um
and i think they'd be like once or twice
where i'd maybe be like angry that
they're asking these questions because
um
there were some tough times like uh in
in in every single um lesson every
single lesson at school
constant questions constant questions i
couldn't ever focus on my lessons i
think i failed a few my gcses just
because of all the questions asking
along
i was having really really really bad
abdominal pains and i thought
my i thought it might have been stones i
don't know what it could have been
anything so i went up to
the mosby when i got my um uh ultrasound
done well i had to wait for ultrasound
that to go to my gp then i
finally got my ultrasound and then yeah
when they did the ultrasound they saw
the um
the testicles which were placed like
either side where you'd think like the
ovaries would be
i guess just to break it down so you had
inverted testicles in your body
yeah did you also have ovaries yeah and
ovaries as well
in the body as well yeah so at this
point you have everything i had
everything i had everything i had the i
had the
male and the female of everything
that moment when you get you get the
scan how did you feel
like everything made sense i felt like
everything made sense i felt like i felt
like at the end of the day
i had i had a hunch i kind of already
knew
uh my need to want to be a boy but then
to want to be a girl didn't make sense
neither to me
i just wanted to one minute literally
just put on you know something nice
like a girl then the next minute put on
something really nice like a boy cause i
could do both
trust me i was a beautiful girl but
obviously like
i don't know i just feel like um i got
so much respect being a man
than i did being a girl so i just
thought to myself well
i might will be amanda so a lot of my
decision was swayed which is sad to say
on other people's opinions but it was
also something that i knew that i wanted
because
i knew that if i would have stayed as a
woman i would always full art what would
life have been like as a man
if i stayed as a man which i am now i i
often sometimes just sometimes think oh
what would life have been like as a
woman
you have a discussion with your parents
then about how did your parents feel
um you know my mom and dad especially my
mom
okay dad you too as well i know you've
tried your hardest to be able to get
your
your head into terms with how you how
you you know we're gonna live as a
family
you know what about if i change my mind
but my mom has always been there
uh you know she came with me to all my
appointments um my endocrinology
appointment she came me to all the
therapy appointments they were four
and she came with me to them and you
know like we kind of celebrated it after
each time you know
this was kind of like um her version of
like
her son going through puberty and
knowing that this is actually natural
and this is normal this is something we
couldn't have helped and you know she's
been so supportive
um so yeah i'm just really grateful
about that you know my brother and
sister
um they they don't know nothing when
they do find out it will be from this
video because obviously i've
told them time and time again but i
don't think i've explained it to them in
the way that
it's kind of hard explaining to your
brother and sister about you being born
a certain way that they
they don't even you know i mean they
don't know nothing about
when did you struggle as a boy uh about
13.
these are quite formative ages what was
dealing like did you have to like
explain things before sexual
interactions yeah so out of common
courtesy i would um explain things
all the time anyway like i would say
straight away like hey you know i've got
um
you know like you know i got a small you
know a small dick or i'd be like oh you
know i've got a [ __ ] or
i think you know because i'm intersex i
feel like
with men they get the aura of a female
even though you can clearly
see that i'm a guy they get the aura of
a female
so they might be confused thinking why
do i like why am i
starting to like this person why am i
starting to like like my my emotions are
changing even though they're straight
and the same things happened women as
well they're like oh so like why am i
like this is when i used to just
identify as just wherever
um it was like one of them kind of
things where and i realized that was
because i don't think that they'd
actually
um quite understood to to full capacity
that i'm a boy and a girl so if a guy
was to kind of fall in love with me then
i suppose
he'd be straight and if a girl fell in
love with me that i suppose
she'd be straight or bi or son i don't
know i don't really research his stuff
is sex different for with different
genders definitely sex is definitely uh
different with different genders um
so with men it would be more of a um
[Music]
less passionate it would be uh we're
gonna have sex by gone i'd be at door
um and then with women it was more or
romantic you know i'd be the guy you
know what i'm saying i'm putting it down
it would be
it's i think i prefer sex with women but
the feeling with men when i had a vagina
haul was nice that i'm not gonna lie
it was really nice but like women give
you
something that men just don't give i
don't think so when you were when you
were 15
you were you wanted to live as a man so
what has to happen
so i got sustained on so it winds up
your face more um
it i went from a size seven to a size
ten and a half
and of course obviously it gives you
more bonus you get a boner like
every single morning like a regular guy
would anyway
um you get very hairy like everywhere
until then your face then becomes like
really hairy i loved it
love it love it love it love it love it
i was just every sec like
oh i it was the best times of my life
actually i'm not even gonna lie
the best times of my life i look amazing
and i kept my i kept my i was going to
the gym every day i was really using
the testosterone to build what i think
should have been built like do you know
what i mean like maybe a little while
ago do you know what i'm saying so it
was a thing where i was
just using the testosterone to the best
of my advantage um
you know i i had more stamina i was
horny every day so it was just beautiful
to actually feel those feelings it was
it was really nice so can you tell us
what surgery entails when you're
intersex
so phalloplasty and metardioplasty so
we're going to start at metoidioplasty
metodioplasty is basically when they
uh they release the clitoris so
instead of hold the clearance being held
down by the ligaments they cut
they cut the ligaments and they release
the clearance which then gives you kind
of like
kind of like what i've got right now
like the baby penis thing going on
and then they um close up the vagina
what they do after that is they create
the
urethral lengthening so they make the
urethra be able to come through the very
tiny hole
in the small penis so the second surgery
is phalloplasty so with phalloplasty
it's a way more invasive surgery which
takes way more of your your time your
life your energy
your mental health but basically they
they chop off the skin on the forearm
they take an artery as well from the
forearm and they take um
some uh some fat and all that so
obviously that the penis can have a bit
of chunking
i've got metroidioplasty and
phantoplasty i wanted two dicks
first of all let's get that straight
secondly i waited to make sure i could
penetrate
with uh with both of them as well at the
same time
because what guy wouldn't want to have
two dicks
what a sentence
[Laughter]
were you happy with that you've done it
i'm happy that i did it now
and i'm also looking forward to um
getting uh
the rest done once i get my erectile
device in i'm gonna get the one where
you can squeeze the balls and then it
goes up like a natural erection i can't
wait
squeezing the ball makes me feel a bit
sick to us
yeah but that's the only way that that's
getting hard
if there's one thing that people can
take away from this video about being
intersex what do you want it to be
i feel like an alien 24 7 like even
right now sitting here i feel like an
alien because i'm talking about
something which
i didn't ask for do you get what i'm
saying i would have loved to have either
been
a natural born beautiful woman with you
know a husband and
a few kids that drive me crazy and a big
house and all that kind of stuff
or i would have preferred to have just
been a regular male
with um you know a normal working penis
um a wife and a few kids that also drive
me crazy but
that is what i would have wanted i
wouldn't i wanted so much confusion
because the confusion is
is immense what more can we do to
make it easier for someone growing up
and their sex
i think to be extremely honest it's just
not mentioning it
a lot of the time but it's just it's
that's never gonna happen people are
never gonna not mention
but when someone finds out you're
intersexed
they ain't ever shutting up about it or
if or they're going to tell their friend
of course they're going to tell their
friend
because it's something that's different
is and when when something's different
obviously you know that people want
everyone to know that you know i'm
saying that oh hi here's my
intersexed friend regente and then next
thing you know the whole
house party or rave or like big event
that i'm at everyone knows
yeah just just don't make a big deal
because intersex basically
like people always think of genitalia
straight away
that well first of all they're confused
and then when they and then when you
explain to them what it all means then
they go straight to this whole genitalia
thing
yeah i'm not gonna ask this your penis
or your vagina unless i want to have sex
with you
so why are you asking to see my dick
because of like trans men and and
trans women and stuff like that intersex
kind of gets
like it's only just been included and
that's why i do videos like this because
i want to make
intersex be like you know something that
people think about when they think about
trans i think about
any of the lgbtqia i want them to think
about the eye and the insects
[Music]
i was sat in my in my parents living
room and it was like
i don't know midnight one o'clock in the
morning i actually flicked the website
back on and in the first half an hour of
the website being live
we sold 30 000 pound in product so to go
from
300 quid a day to 30 000 pound in half
an hour
everything good sold out it was it was
absolutely mind blowing